in mid-2020 as the coronavirus pandemic
was exploding around the world
this is what the situation looked like
right here in germany
the country was hailed the world's
shining star of coronavirus containment
germany germany by comparison germany
where hospitals are not yet overwhelmed
but the number of deaths in germany has
remained lower than many other countries
now things look very different than they
did last summer
while countries like the uk and israel
are going back to normalcy
[Applause]
germany has been under some form of
lockdown for over
six months on germany's intensive care
wards
this is what the third wave looks like
hospitals have been pleading with the
government to tighten restrictions
going on like this will destroy the
economy
will destroy the people and will cost
lives
so how did we get here how did germany
a country known for its efficiency love
of planning and rationality lose control
of its covet 19 response
problem one indecision germany was able
to flatten the first coronavirus curve
by
acting fast in march 2020 politicians
were quick to impose an
almost complete lockdown as the second
wave started picking up speed
critics say decision makers
underestimated the virus
much to the frustration of scientists
who had called for harsher measures
much earlier
it was november when politicians finally
took action
they imposed a partial lockdown
needless to say this partial lockdown
was
only partially successful
not only are these measures still in
place but they've been tightened
germany never went into a complete
lockdown
politicians were hesitant to fully shut
down workplaces such
as factories
on top of that new variants have made
the virus more aggressive
criticism of politicians indecision has
grown louder
moments
the inability of politicians to quickly
decide on uniform measures
it's partially down to how the country
is governed
germany is a federal republic decision
making is not centralized in the hands
of the chancellor in berlin
instead each of the country's 16 states
has its own government which can decide
on things like law enforcement or
education
this system is there for a reason
germany evolved from
hundreds of little royal states after
world war ii
federalism was enshrined in law to avoid
falling into a dictatorship
ever again but this system also means
when it comes to fighting the pandemic
that every government has the right to
decide on its own rules
in an attempt to find a unified approach
there have been regular discussions
between chancellor angela merkel
and the 16th state premiers
which unlike the spread of the
coronavirus can be
very very slow these meetings would
sometimes last
4 hours
they would go into details like should
schools open what about hairdressers
would a curfew help and the list goes on
in the end there would often
be no uniform measures to combat the
virus
people in the population are frustrated
nobody knows anymore what the
regulations are right now
i think it's chaos especially if you
look at the different vaccination
strategies
in early april a poll showed that four
out of five germans are unhappy with how
the federal
and state governments are handling the
pandemic another reason why germany has
had a hard time
getting out of this ongoing lockdown and
fighting the pandemic is
bureaucracy
[Music]
in a pandemic tracking cases is crucial
to break down infection chains
and slow down exponential growth in
germany it's the over 400 gesundheits
empta
or public health departments that are in
charge of tracking infections
their methods are sometimes very
outdated
they are still working with mostly with
pen papers telephone they try to do
contact tracing and it doesn't really
work
covet has exposed just how antiquated
germany's bureaucracy
actually is for example how much it
relies on this
this is a fax machine
[Music]
a technology that's nearing its 170th
birthday
[Music]
pax machines will scan in an image on
one side
transmit it through a phone line and
print it out again
on the other side magic in germany
these things were used to transmit covet
19 test results
foreign
an army of german bureaucrats retyping
facts covet 19 test results back into
their computers
this was the reality in germany's
healthcare centers until january of
2021 when the country's health minister
made the following
[Music]
[Music]
bureaucracy also played a role in the
vaccine rollout
of course the rollout was slow because
germany doesn't yet have the doses it
needs
but even with the vaccines that are
available
getting an appointment can be
frustrating initially
those entitled to a vaccine were
notified by snail mail
then they would have to call a hotline
or go online to schedule an
appointment call centers and online
services
were overwhelmed in one case one woman
reported she had to call almost
100 times to get through here's one
particularly hair-raising
example vaccine appointments are
organized
by priority groups the elderly for
example
are up first but in lower saxony the
authorities had trouble
generating a list with people over 80.
so the post office had to resort to
writing letters
to people with old fashioned names
like fritz hans or adoif
despite all the problems along the way
germany's vaccination campaign is slowly
but surely picking up speed
and it's not just picked up speed it's
really gained momentum
the country is getting more vaccine
doses citizens who qualify for a vaccine
can get their shots at their family
doctors
and not just in the big vaccination
centers
a new federal coronavirus law has been
passed it requires
all states to implement a basic set of
measures when covet 19 cases
pass a certain threshold as infection
rates fall
doctors say these new measures will save
thousands of lives
politicians vying for the chancellorship
in september's federal elections
have made e-governance and
digitalization a
central point of their campaign goals
the pandemic response has highlighted
many of germany's shortcomings in areas
such as
digitalization and bureaucracy
things that will have to be dealt with
by the next generation of policy makers
if the country hopes to regain its
reputation of being a
world leader in efficiency
you